if you look through the newspapers if
you watch TV if you survey media in
general a sense would be that faith is
closely associated with violence that's
what media reports on faith and violence
and yet if you speak to religious people
often they will speak about faith not
just in conjunction with helping them to
flourish as human beings but also
helping them to live in peace with one
another faith for them is associated not
so much with violence but with peace
indeed with also peacemaking the topic
of our discussion is how can we see
faith as a resource for peacemaking how
can we see faith not as a cause of
conflicts but as a way to bring people
together under what condition faith
functions in such ways and what needs to
happen to promote this kind of positive
role of faith in peacemaking and in
order to explore this topic we will
discuss the issue of the role of faith
in the conflict in Ireland and in
particular zero in on the contribution
of faith to making possible the Good
Friday Accords